the Joe Rogan experience if I was coming
like off the couch so to speak six
months would be a little more
appropriate are you ever off the couch
only if I'm injured and I've only been
injured in any significant way since
ultra since they're altering running
once for about five weeks seven I had a
stress fracture on my right sacred alla
it's kind it's basically on your
tailbone oh ouch yeah yeah the [ __ ]
happened so what I think I don't know
it's hard to know for sure but what was
the way was described to me when I was
going in and getting eye stuff checked
out was what likely happened was I had
such a history and kind of flat running
that I was actually preparing for a race
had a lot more climbing descending so I
started changing my training to more
climbing and ascending and when I did
that like one thing that sometimes
happens when you're running a lot of
flat hard surfaces is your like ankles
and your hips can get pretty tight from
that real like kind of uniform like
mechanic that you're doing so like my
range of motion was semi limited so when
I was doing some of that hard downhill
and uphill running I just probably
wasn't very efficient with my form and
it ended up the kind of were talking
before those impact forces ended up in
the wrong spot and then the stress
fracture occurred that is crazy you
broke your ass you literally broke your
ass always talked about all he was
busting his ass like you actually did so
where is it Jamie right there oh Jesus
Christ it's so it's it literally is your
ass bone you a really goofy thing about
it too was Wow when I first had the pain
surface for that it was kind of in like
the like lower back glute area is where
it surfaced so I thought I had like a
sciatic issue like I went into the
doctor and they were like okay let's try
some like Active Release therapy and
let's see if we can get this thing to
loosen up and we just were working on
working on it and like it would like
clear up where I wouldn't notice it if I
was walking around but then every time
I'd go for a run or try to go for a run
I get that sharp pain right away and so
after about I think it was maybe four
weeks or so we just we had been doing a
ton of Active Release a ton of mobility
work and then like it wasn't going away
so he's like well let's just get an MRI
and see what's going on in there and
they did the MRI got the results back
and he said there's nothing there
so you start running again so I started
running again I ran like I think it was
two or three days maybe very short like
two miles and then three
than maybe 5 or something like that and
then I got a call back from the doctor
and he's like well it turns out we took
a second look at the MRI there is a
stress fracture I told him like well
I've just ran the first three pain-free
days I ever I have since this this issue
oh nine [ __ ] yeah well and I think what
he said maybe was going on there was it
was I mean was a very fine stress
fracture it wasn't I mean sometimes when
people have a fracture on their sacral
ax it's like a big enough fracture where
like it can be out for like a year and
oh yeah yeah so it can be a really bad
injury but he said maybe the mobility
and the strength work I was doing while
I had that to try to rehab kind of
strengthen the areas around it enough
that when I just was running flat really
slow really easy that protected that
area number I didn't feel the pain
anymore so after that I think I took
another like two weeks off completely
just to make sure before I started
building back up and then I started kind
of building back up again
[Applause]